naturally monumental expectations
accompany the first halflife game in 13
years and for the iconic franchises
return to come in the form of a VR
exclusive is undoubtedly bold but at
each step of the way
half-life Alex proves that almost
everything the franchise did best
thrives in VR the environmental puzzles
that require a keen eye
the threat of a headcrab jumping for
your face the cryptic storytelling the
series staples are as powerful as ever
here and in its greatest moments
half-life Alex confidently shows you why
it couldn't have been done any other way
a true half-life form the entire game
goes from morning to night in a single
shot of first-person action in which you
as Alyx Vance trek through city 17
at first it's the savior dad Eli Vance
from the clutches of the combine which
then leads to uncovering the nature of
the vault that massive floating
structure in the sky with a cheeky
sidekick Russell in your ear and a
trusty prophetic vordigan who comes in
clutch Alex is more than prepared
there's a newfound intimacy captured in
doing the things at half life always
asks of you because it's a vr game the
way you look at and process your
surroundings fundamentally changes thus
making the solutions to environmental
puzzles more of a personal
accomplishment than before simply
finding the right objects to progress
was fine with a keyboard and mouse but
when it's your own hands turning the
valves pulling the levers or hitting the
switches while turning your head to see
the results
these become enticing gameplay mechanics
rather than a means of breaking up the
pace without waypoints or objective
markers to guide you subtle visual cues
and calculate a level design lead you to
the solutions and progress feels earned
because of that you may not have the
gravity gun here but the spirit of its
physics based interaction lives through
the gravity gloves both as a sensible
thematic fit and tool for proper VR
gameplay they allow you to magnetically
pull objects from afar and catching them
midair is always satisfying especially
when snatching a grenade off a combine
soldier to throw it back in their face
which just as important is Alex's
multi-tool which serves as a way to
engage in the game simple yet enjoyable
spatial puzzles rewiring circuitry to
unlock paths forward is the multi-tools
most crucial function though so you'll
need a sharp eye tracing electrical
currents and cables to progress
half-life Alex revolves around the
balance of puzzle elements and
suspenseful combat it might not have the
bombastic fights from series pass but
most of that has been exchanged for
close encounters sometimes tapping into
horror that half-life had only
previously toyed with headcrabs aren't
just annoying pests they will literally
latch on to your head or cause the
occasional jump scare the same goes for
barnacles you do not want your own
virtual body dragged up toward the
ceiling by its disgusting slimy tongue
other scenarios have you navigating
through pitch-black darkness with your
wrist mounted flashlights there's also
an entire chapter dedicated to an
invincible mutant that can't see but has
sharp hearing to chase you down combine
soldiers may still be dummies but when
they're coming for you and VR their
threat becomes imminent
you'll physically duck in and out of
cover and peek around corners ready to
bust shots and frantically reload like
any good VR shooter requires though here
in its distinctly half-life form
you'll hear a combine radio chatter and
the high-pitched ring of them flatlining
all the while the odd comfort of the
old-school techno beats during the
heated firefights kick in there are many
types of combine soldiers or styles of
encounters but I was always eager to
face them head-on in each scenario alex
packs light when it comes to weapons
with only a pistol shotgun and SMG all
three have a few upgrades to make them
more effective which must be done at
combine fabricator stations using
resident the only real collectible item
in the game animals often scarce and
resins tucked away around corners so
scavenging is a core element further
emphasizing Alex's scrappy nature and
honestly the slim arsenal fits the
styled combat sequences with each weapon
effective in their own right
overall half-life Alex takes many of the
concepts we've seen evolve since V ARS
inception and distills them to their
fundamentals it brings them together to
create a VR experience that's a full
cohesive whole and the game gives
multiple accessibility options to
mitigate motion sickness or make the
game playable if you have physical
limitations all that said there are a
few shortcomings doors and mechanisms
you need to grip don't always react to
your movements the way you would expect
and sometimes they're just too many
unimportant objects that obscure the
thing that you're actually trying to
pull in with their gravity gloves
thankfully these instances are rare
enough as to not drag down otherwise
intuitive mechanics now the front half
of the game does settle into a bit of a
routine you may start to see through
some of the trite aspects of the combat
challenges or scripted sequences and the
reliance on narrow corridors for
stretches and one point I wondered where
the game was going but there's a turning
point
and the practice routines pay off as the
game escalates the stakes you'll be
struck by the awe-inspiring sights the
thrill of firefights that ramp up in
intensity while performing the VR
specific mechanics and the unbearable
suspense of some levels yet all those
pale in comparison to the final hour
when half-life Alex solidifies itself as
the boldest the series has ever been the
very concept of VR becomes the core
narrative device your hands and by
extension
Alex's actions are fundamental to the
delivery of its monumental moment only
then will you really understand why VR
was the only way this game could have
even existed and it delivers something
that's surreal revelatory and incredibly
empowering half-life alex has
far-reaching implications for the future
of the franchise both and where it goes
next and what forms future games can
even take and in true half-life fashion
more questions and answers linger but
for good reason
and now without a reminder of why you
love the series to begin with it made
good on its shift to VR elevating many
of the aspects we've come to love about
the series the intimacy of VR brings you
closer to a world you thought you knew
over the past 22 years and as it
concludes half-life Alex will hit you
with powerful unforgettable moments that
truly transcend VR tropes and make the
13-year weight all worth it
[Music]